Welcome, everybody, to another Zoom call, so let's just jump right into it for those that are relatively do remember to utilize the member site or the member site.
You're going to see a downspins, anything new, that's how you can access the past Zoom calls.
You'll see links to our video site and such.
And tons more information on that, so make sure you use the member site.
Okay, let's jump into the questions.
First question, how long can a person be on Ivermectin and Orphan Bendisel?
Well, remember, there's a few qualifications, if it's not affecting your liver or your kidneys in a negative fashion, they're still limitations, so you would basically make that decision based upon how well you're doing.
The person is in, let's say, if my cancer is in remission, and I'm doing well, see me lean in my, you know, what, maybe what if I'm measuring my, a tumor marker, let's say PSA or my CA, 15, 3, and it's relatively stable.
I would say that my cancer's not growing, and I have no other signs of growth.
Is there a time that you would pause it? Yes, it is a drug, these are drugs, so they can't have other ill effects on your body, so there is nothing wrong with pausing something, especially a drug.
You can start to develop an immunity to the drug, and it, you know, can decrease in its function. Everybody's different, not everybody's, this is going to happen to, but if I was relatively stable and I was doing well, I think I would go on a little vacation from the medications for a period of time, and then you could always go back on.
So there's nothing wrong with what's called pulsing your medication, so it's just something to think about. It's not right for everybody, it's certainly not right for everybody to stay on it, it's not right for everybody to go off of it.
But, um, technically, how long can a person be on Iverbecht and Fed Medizol? There's literally no data out there. You know, there's been no, you know, major studies as far as, you know, length of time to be on it.
I mean, typically, if the person's cancer is growing, you're going to increase the dose of Iverbecht and Fed Medizol to knock this down and knock this out, but if it starts to regress and you start to go into a more stable situation where you would say that your cancer is regressing or your, or your, you know, um,
a state where all your numbers are coming back to normal. This isn't something you just stay on the rest of your life, so it's something to think about as far as, um, as far as the length of time that a person's going to be on it, so that's a good question.
Next question, what are your thoughts on the Zyto scans that many acupuncturists said nutritionists are running these days? Are they accurate and identified bacteria and viruses?
Um, I'd say yes and no, so that I think they're beneficial on the frequency scans can be beneficial to identify that a person may have a bacteria or a virus, but I've always said they are not something that you would quote, unquote, diagnose off of.
So if it's another test, for instance, if I run a CBC and I have an elevated white blood cell code and I didn't have an elevated white blood cell code in my previous CBCs, that I could say that there's a high likelihood that I have an infection, that I would compare that with the differential of the complete blood code.
Complete blood count. If my neutrophils were elevated and my lymphocytes were suppressed, I'd say that it's pretty good chance that it's a bacterial infection.
If that was reversed, my lymphocytes were elevated, my neutrophils were suppressed and it's a pretty good chance that it's a viral infection.
But can I just run a Zyto scan to know if it's a bacteria or a virus?
It will give you clues. I think a blood test is going to give you more accurate clues.
Remember, a Zyto scan is picking up frequencies and it's picking up frequencies quite quickly, so there can be a lot of errors in that as well.
My argument against the scans is when practitioners use it and tell people you have Lyme disease or you have this disease.
I think that's dangerous. I don't think it's accurate. I don't think it's proper medicine.
I think that's, is it mild practice?
Any more than some of the things that the medical doctor says, I don't think you can just diagnose based upon just one test of anything.
All your tests give you clues. Yes, if you came up, let's say you came up positive on Lyme, a Zyto scan.
Does that mean you have Lyme? In my book, no, it doesn't mean you have Lyme. Does it mean that you could have bacteria and or viruses?
Yes. If you came up very high and multiple bacteria and they gave you the name of the bacteria when I diagnose it and say this is the exact bacteria that you have based upon the Zyto scan,
I would say no, but is there a greater chance that you may have a bacterial infection? Yes, but you'd compare it with other labs too.
If your CBC was normal, your white blood cell, let's say, was 4.5.
And your neutrophils in the facites were within normal range too, but then you showed high bacteria on a Zyto scan.
I would doubt that that was accurate. Is there anything wrong with doing some treatment on the right based upon the Zyto scan?
Absolutely not. It's not going to be invasive, nothing like that. Would you use an antibiotic based upon a positive bacteria on a Zyto scan? No, I wouldn't because that's going to be more invasive.
So long story short, any test that you do, it has imperfections, nothing is going to be perfect gold standard.
So you use a test wisely to give you clues. So you run a Zyto scan, you came up positive for virus, let's say, Epstein-Barr virus.
Does that mean that you have Epstein-Barr virus? I would say no, it doesn't.
You would look at other tests as well. If your white blood cell count again was within normal range and your lymphocyte count was within normal range,
this Zyto scan could have been picking up a past Epstein-Barr virus. Most of us have latent Epstein-Barr virus.
If you did an IgG antibody test for Epstein-Barr virus, probably 8 out of 10 people which are positive and yet not have any signs of current Epstein-Barr virus because almost everybody has been exposed to Epstein-Barr virus.
Now, like I said, then the Zyto scan picks it up and then people run with that, say, you have Epstein-Barr virus, that's your problem and we need to treat for this.
So they go in a whole treatment program for that and it's not accurate.
So I would just be careful using any test as your gold standard, use every test as giving you clues and guiding your treatment.
And so there's nothing wrong with using it if you just use it wisely with that understanding.
I thought the RIF would be noisier but the new programs of the Atelier Robin often have no sound is this normal.
Yes, so the difference with the Atelier Robin and the true RIF at least one difference is with the Atelier Robin you can run harmonics with it.
So most of the new, most of the programming that I have created with the Atelier Robin is written in harmonics.
I wrote all the programs of the Atelier Robin.
So if it's running a harmonic in the program that you're running often there'll be no sound whatsoever compared to the true RIF which can be loud at different times, especially running a lower frequency.
The Atelier Robin you could have sound at different times if you're running a lower frequency that's not in a harmonic but typically if you're running a harmonic you're going to have very little to no sound.
So yes, that is normal.
Should the rest of my family be taking digestive enzymes?
I'm taking clear digest per your recommendation and I've read your posts, my spools on the blog on Hpilora and I think that my family would benefit from treating that as well.
Well, one could argue that decrease in hydrochloric acid production of the stomach is fairly ubiquitous and it can also be argued that that can be a major player in the beginning of many, you know, diseases and dysfunctions in our body.
So when we have a decrease HCl production of stomach, we're going to have a decrease in our ability to digest food.
So then foods going to go into the small intestine only partially digested. It's going to be an irritant. We have the increase ability to end up with the leaky gut issues.
Leaky gut issues going to lead to food sensitivities and antibodies made to peptides to different foods and it could cause this inflammatory process that could cause inflammation in the brain and elsewhere in the body and it could be a whole cycle.
Also with a decrease stomach acid, we end up with a decrease in our ability to kill primary pathogens that come via food.
We eat food, it has bacteria, it has parasites, it has all sorts of things that should not affect us if we have a healthy hydrochloric acid production.
Remember, your stomach should have a pH of about 1.5 to 2.5 because of its proper secretion of hydrochloric acid through the prinal cells in the stomach.
That's what makes hydrochloric acid. So if you have proper acidity in the stomach because your prinal cells are doing their job, then you will kill primary pathogens.
So if you're eating food that can have pathogens, bacteria, viruses, parasites, you have adequate HCl in the stomach, it kills those and you don't end up with any infections from these things.
However, most people, like I said, have a decrease stomach acid and therefore primary pathogens get into the stomach, can pass through the stomach wall, get into the intestinal tract, you can end up with parasites, you can end up with bacterial problems etc.
Also, a proper HCl will keep a balance so that you don't get what this person asked a question about.
Hpylora, Hpylora is short for helical back to pylora, the number one bacterial infection worldwide according to the World Health Organization, it's considered ubiquitous, it is part of our normal floor, but it gets out of balance when we have a decrease hydrochloric acid.
So hypochlorhydride, decrease hydrochloric acid, can lead to Hpylora infections, which are the cause of stomach and duodenal ulcers.
Also, they can go systemically, it is a major cause of heart disease, still the number one cause of death in the United States, and it is the number one cause of stomach and duodenal cancer and can cause other cancers as well.
Hpylora is a big band player and all sorts of diseases.
Also, if you have a decreased hydrochloric acid in your stomach, you will not secrete intrinsic factor that is necessary for you to absorb B12, so you're going to end up with the B12 deficiency as well.
It is a factor in anemias, so yes, would a product like clear digest that has hydrochloric acid and digestive enzymes be good for everybody?
Yeah, it would be. Oh, wait a second, I thought we were made, the image of God and we were made perfect wire, we having so many problems with hydrochloric acid production.
Well, it happens to be that foods that contain all these chemicals that were consuming the dyes and colors and flavorings and additives and pesticides and herbicides and all this stuff damage.
The primal cells in the stomach and we don't make as much HCl was an answer to the ultimate cause, so supply HCl and digestive enzymes.
Well, excuse me, we'll help us identify the stomach and help decrease all cause many, many causes of diseases, so yes, they have long answer for yeah, that would be good for everybody to take.
Next question, can a person take too much vitamin D? Yes, you can.
As a matter of fact, it's hard to discern sometimes because some labs won't measure the total vitamin D, they'll just say greater than 150 on your labs, so it's like well, what do you mean?
Is it 160 or is it 600? Well, some labs don't give you the exact number beyond, you know, a specific number like 150.
Now personally, I am under the belief that it would be good for somebody with cancer to have a vitamin D level of 80 to 150.
However, when you get vitamin D levels up to 300 because you're taking 20,000 IUs a day and you have for the last five years and you don't have any VDR defects in your genes, you're absorbing a lot of vitamin D that you're taking and you could have elevated vitamin D levels, that's why I suggest people get their vitamin D levels tested.
If it is beyond 200, I don't suggest you continue taking or a vitamin D.
So yes, I do think there can be dangers in too much vitamin D. Is there any data that shows vitamin D toxicity?
There's just a few papers in the literature back from I think the 1980s where somebody was taking high dose vitamin D for a period of time and they did have vitamin D toxicity, but anything can be too much of a good thing, can be a bad thing.
So yes, I do think that a person can get too much of anything, so vitamin D is one of those things. So I don't take a person should be taking 25,000 IUs a vitamin D constantly without getting their vitamin D levels checked.
If you're taking 5,000 IUs a vitamin D on a daily basis, you're never going to have too much vitamin D.
It's the people that are taking 20 to 25, I've had talked to people that were taking 50,000 IUs a vitamin D a day because they saw some Instagram video of somebody saying that that was good for you.
Well, anything is where you just got to be careful, there's there's anybody could go on Instagram that isn't this isn't a practitioner or maybe a retired practitioner, they can say all sorts of things that that don't get them into trouble because you know they're not technically a practitioner.
They're not licensed any longer, so if somebody follows their advice via a video on Instagram, they're not going to be held liable, but I think you're morally liable.
That's what bothers me about Instagram and this not because it seems like these people are just saying things in order to get just hints and to get followers and I think there's danger in that.
Bring that up again in a quite other question somebody has down here, so.
Next question, are there any program that the right that a person should not run?
Well, I've always said you have to be careful with with bacterial programs and really the live program.
So the live Borrelia program you have to be careful.
If you're running that because you could liberate because Borrelia of burgodorphy, the main culprit in Lyme disease is a gram negative bacteria and gram negative bacteria have lipopolysaccharides in their cell membranes.
If you kill them quickly, which you can do, running the Borrelia program, you'll liberate a lot of lipopolysaccharides and you'll get side effects.
From that, called Herkseimer reaction, that would be the only thing that I'd say be careful running would be the Lyme program.
I'm not wrong with running it, but I'm not saying don't run it but go slow at that and see how you react to it.
Some people may have Lyme and not know it at all. I'll run this live program if they get sick afterwards.
But it's a sign that you may have Lyme if you got sick after it and you need to run it but maybe you need to go slow with it.
I have a large feeling that fell out of my wisdom tooth and it's been like that for over a year now.
The back edge of the tooth is gone. I finally found a new dentist after insurance changed.
Is it better to pull the tooth or get a crowd as far as health goes?
I worry about cavitations with pulling the tooth and bacteria getting the tooth sealed in with a crowd.
I know you're a dentist but I'm wondering if you have any insight.
Well, it really depends on how much damage is to the tooth.
It's salvageable. Yes, if you do get the tooth, if you just get it filled and they can build up the tooth with the filling, sometimes that's the best.
Can you seal in bacteria by crowding it? It is possible.
The worst is getting a root canal done because then the whole tooth is a hotel for bacteria.
But usually if you have a crowd and it's a tight fitting crowd where there's no gap in the crowd, it's sealed with a sealant.
So there's no air in there. Then the chance of bacteria in there is much less.
So again, I'd refer to your dentist in this. I'm not a dentist, but is there a chance if you pull the tooth that you can end up with cavitations?
Yes, if they do an x-ray, they're going to see how deep the roots are and that can be an issue.
So yeah, you're going to have to weigh all those things out.
If the roots are strong enough and healthy enough and the tooth is still healthy, other than that damaged part, get it filled and put a crown on so that you still have use of the tooth might be the best way to go.
Here's the question I was going to add to from the other one.
I've been reading Dr. Brian Artis's info on the health benefits of nicotine.
Yes, I've seen some of his Instagram videos on this.
And he's one of those practitioners that I don't know that he's practicing any longer and he says many outlandish things that bother me.
So yeah, I really struggle with that. I think he was the person that says he's going to wear a nicotine patch the rest of his life, but it's the cure all for everything basically.
And he's probably selling nicotine patches.
So, however, I've also read that these patches can have issues for people with leaky gut and MDHFR defects.
I'd be taking it for pain with live. What are your thoughts?
It's still a drug. It's not just pure, you know, organic nicotine from a plant.
It's still a drug that you're dealing with. It still has the chance of having side effects.
It still is, you know, there's not been, you know, full testing on this, you know, not the jack down full testing with, you know, you know, a peer reviewed, you know, double blind study on everything.
I don't know what I'm asking for, but it's still with your, with your making claims on Instagram that are, that are not necessarily substantiated by anything.
There's just dangers in that that everybody shouldn't be doing this. Everybody should be doing this. This is a cure all for all this stuff.
You know, there's, these people have, you know, there's maybe backlash from the medical community and these people, but they're so, they have so many followers, thousands, maybe millions of followers.
And their videos are getting millions of hits and they're making a blast and crazy amount of money off of these things.
It's really hard to, you trust them. Okay, you look at my Instagram videos, most of them have maximum length, 30 views. Okay, I don't get any of those views and praise God, I don't, praise God, our channel is so small.
And that I would rather take care of a lot less people and do the best possible thing for them to be making outlandish claims in order just to get hits and just to get views so that we could make money.
We don't monetize any of our channels. So I just think there's a conflict of interest there. And especially when these people are not licensed to practice anymore, they have no, there's no danger for them to get in trouble with boards.
And at the unprobe boards and pro state government institutional oversight, but we have to have some moral oversight and some of the things that are being said and done out there.
And I do think that a lot of things in the quote unquote alternative community are are just done to get to make a landish claims to get hits to get followers to get to sell products when, when there's, when there's no,
there's no, there's no real data behind it. So we just had to be careful of that. So that's what I have against Instagram and social media.
You know, literally I just basically I'm not making a social media post anymore because it's just bothers me so much of the misuse and abuse out there.
And that's just my soap box about some of the stuff. Let's say a nicotine is bad for everybody. I'm just saying it's not good for everybody either none of this stuff is.
It's all about balance and this is where I just think it's so important for everybody to have that a lot of reasons to have a personal relationship with your heavenly father that you could be seeking asking for wisdom.
So that you we don't get sucked into things. We all need to be like, Lord, you just gotta give me your wisdom and teach me your ways so that I don't go down the wrong pathway.
Give me peace about all the decisions that I'm making. That's why I want you to bounce these kind of questions off of me.
So, you know, it hurts me when I see people I started taking this start taking this start taking this like whoa.
You know, you get on the Zoom call just talk let's talk about it. I'm not against all these things but I am against just jumping into it because I saw a video about it.
So, should nicotine be beneficial for some people? Yeah, maybe can nicotine be negative for some people? Yes, it certainly can be.
So, if you really want me to test you on it, I can test you on it at a cheek swab.
If you're going to use it, I would test it. I would go real slow. If you decide that you feel like you're led to start methylene blue or something else out there that people are making very outlandish claims, where it can be good for people.
But most of the claims are ridiculous. So, but just go slow with it. Just that's all I would say.
Next question. I'm taking Iverbectin and I'm up to 120 milligrams daily. Remember that the dose for Iverbectin for cancer would be a half a milligram poor kilogram weight.
So, you convert your weight into kilograms and you start at a half a milligram per kilogram of your weight. And then you could slowly titrate up from there.
And last week since I've increased the dose, I've had extra severe brain fog and my memory is greatly impacted as well. Could these be side effects of the Iverbectin? Should I cut back?
And how slowly should I increase again? So, could these be side effects of the Iverbectin? Yes, they could be.
Should you cut back? Yeah, probably. Should you go back up again? Well, it's good. It depends on where you're at with your cancer.
If your answer to that question is, well, my cancer is pretty stable. I don't think it's growing. There's no other. There's no.
Some objective signs that it's growing. There's no objective signs that it's growing with different blood tests with PET scans with CT scans with tumor markers.
That I wouldn't necessarily raise my dose. Matter of fact, you might want to lower your dose. If there is subjective and or objective signs that the cancer is going in the wrong direction that it's growing.
But yes, then maybe you slowly go back up, cut back on your dose, see if those symptoms go away and then you can go up slowly. So, that's how I would at least approach that.
I'm taking the Carlisle brand black cohosh, 750 milligram tablets, about three per day and I'm still having hot flashes during the day and also that wake me up at night.
Would you suggest a different brand or a higher dose of what I'm taking? They worked for me three years ago, but not now.
Okay, so somebody who is ER and or PR and or her two positive negative, return to positive cancer, you know, you're trying to get your estrogen levels down.
So, you want your estrogen levels to be down because you don't want your estrogen levels to be blocking the estrogen beta receptor.
So, that's the whole idea. So, it's a kind of a catch 22. If my estrogen levels then go down, that could be better to help my body kill the cancer.
However, my estrogen levels go down, that could be bad because I'm going to end up with hot flashes.
So, it's this balancing act with somebody with cancer. Now, if your cancers in a relative state of remission again, then you could use some natural things to help balance estrogen so that you don't have the side effects of low estrogen, aka hot flashes and such.
If that's the case, hey, my cancers in relative state of remission and I'm using like Kauhosh to try to balance my hormones, but it's not working now.
Well, a couple things could be going on. Remember, some of the brands of supplements that contain herb, herbs, sometimes the batch is just a bad batch.
And if we sent it into a organic chemistry lab and tested it, it might not actually have 750 milligram black Kauhosh.
It might only have 7 milligrams seriously, a black Kauhosh. That's why it's not working. These companies are getting their products in almost, you know, most of these herbs are coming from China.
And if they're not checking each batch to, you know, be very specific with, you know, what is rigid on the label, which a lot of these companies, like I think the Carlisle brand, which is kind of an off cheaper brand.
It's, you know, there, it could be all over the board as far as what's actually in the capsules.
So, A, you could switch to a different brand. You could be, you have a bunch of that try taking a higher dose.
But again, it would be based upon, you know, where you're at with your cancer because you don't want to, you know, do something that could relatively raise your spike your estrogen and then cause blockage of the receptor site, which could possibly increase the growth of your cancer.
So, a lot of reasons why a certain herb is not working for somebody, one of them would certainly be the quality of the product itself.
I just purchased a weight loss product called Fix, which is made with organic hops, no other ingredients but purified water.
I didn't think to investigate it until today after I paid for it. And I'm reading conflicting things about taking it with hormone positive breast cancer.
Yeah, typically you won't use hops with, or with hormone positive cancers.
There was a product that came out a few years ago. It didn't really catch on. It was using hops as a pain reliever.
Because there's multiple studies that can, oh, that showed hops can be an acute pain reliever.
The problem with that was that you had to take a lot of it. It didn't seem to work, but there's a lot of studies that showed it work.
Now, I never carried that product because if you had hormone positive cancers, you weren't really supposed to take hops.
So, yeah, I think you might want to gift that to somebody that you know.
Okay, questions on the chat. Remember, if you have other questions that you think of that you didn't submit.
If you're new to this, all these questions that I just went through, these were submitted.
Where did you submit those? Well, they submitted them on the member site. Then there's a on the tab zoom calls you.
There's a blue box that says submit your questions and you submit your questions right off of that.
But of course, you're not required to submit your questions to ask questions. This is a live zoom call.
So, many people chat in the questions. I think everybody can see the chat.
So, if you have a question, feel free to chat in a question.
First question for the chat. Are there any right programs that I should not run since I have Wilder brand disorder, slow blood clotting?
Can't take any anti-inflammatory drugs or supplements.
Um, I, um, no, I don't think so. I don't, I don't think it's their beauty restriction.
I can't think off to not my head if there be any restrictions to the right programs.
Um, yeah, not off to my head. I can't think of any right programs that you should not be ready.
Next question I think is a comment about the Zito scan question.
You said exactly. Then, then they want to treat you with their supplements.
Yeah, so, and I'm not against using the Zito scan again to give you clues, but to say, you have this, take this.
It's just about having a balance with that. I do not think you should diagnose off of those things. I don't think I think that is dangerous.
Um, but, uh, you know, if a person, you can't argue that a person maybe took some supplements based on the Zito scan and they felt better.
But again, if it's, you got to be careful, they're just using it to sell supplements, you know, it's just a balance there.
So again, you know, use your discernment, pray for discernment and everything that you do.
Next question, what are your thoughts on corded stem cell treatment in addition to our programs?
So stem cell treatment, we're not talking about stem cell transplants.
So stem cell transplant would be a treatment for leukemias.
That's totally different. So corded stem cell treatment, it can be either injectables or it can be IV, um, can be very beneficial for different things.
So, um, I had several doctor friends that were doing stem cell injections for degenerative, these degenerative hips, um, with great success.
It, the problem with it, it wasn't, uh, you typically had to redo it, it wasn't long term success, um, but I know they're doing corded stem cell IVs and injections for all sorts of different things.
Now, I do know that they're, it's not as big anymore, but it used, it was big about, um, eight years ago, when stem cells first came out, they thought there was going to be the treatment and the cure for everything, like so many different things.
And, um, it was used in some alternative cancer clinics. Now, I had a big problem with that.
Matter of fact, I read a book of a practitioner who wrote a book on stem cells and he was considered kind of an authoritarian on this on stem cells at the time, because he was kind of at the cutting edge of it and he was doing it in his clinic.
Um, and for cancer patients, um, they did not see six the success with it that they thought they were going to see and I don't know if they are actually continuing to do that procedure for cancer.
Now, the struggle with it with cancer is that stem cells by definition can be pluric coated, which means they can turn into different tissues.
So, uh, whatever the body needs to do with those stem cells, it can make different cells.
The struggle with a person with cancer using stem cells is that it can turn into and stimulate cancer growth.
So, that was the fear in most practitioners use of stem cells for cancer. That's why most practitioners did not do stem cells with cancer.
I had one patient years ago that was from Canada that did that went to Colorado to get stem cells for her cancer and she passed away.
Now, I'm not saying it was from the stem cells, but her cancer did go crazy and she died. I don't know what it was from.
Um, so I've never been a fan of cord and stem cells for cancer. Now, if you don't have cancer, you're using cord and stem cells for other things like early dementia or Parkinson's and things, by all means, I don't think there's a harm to it.
So, if you don't have a cancer diagnosis, I don't think that there's a real harm to using stem cell therapy.
Um, I don't know, you know, if there's a practitioner that's doing it for dementia or Parkinson's or something like that with great success, then by all means, it's something to think about.
The other therapy for dementia or Parkinson's that I would consider highly would be, um, hyperbaric chambers, but you would want to sit before you purchase a hyperbaric chamber, you would want to find a clinic that has a hyperbaric chamber and see if you can go in it safely.
I personally, with my sinus issues, I can't use a hyperbaric chamber.
Um, some people get claustrophobic and some people, they just can't do it. So it's something to think about.
But cord and stem cells for non cancer conditions can be extremely beneficial. Like I said, I had practitioner friends that used them for injectables as for knee issues, severe degeneration and knees, severe degeneration and hips.
Um, with pretty good success rate, um, couple of my good friends that were very honest with me, you know, they said they saw 60 to 70% success rate with it.
However, they did say that typically in a year, so they had to do it again.
But still, if you want to prevent show knee surgery and the replacement or hip replacement, I'd go down that route before I'd go with replacement surgery.
So I think it's a good choice.
Oh, next comment. Thank you for your balance on holistic medicine.
Um, example, Dr artist, it's a good reminder for all of us when we are ill.
It's easy to be so gullible and it's not, I don't mean to be little anybody that's listening to these things and like, oh my gosh, this could be the cure for everything.
I'm just trying to remind you, you know, I see these all the time and it's like it just, it just, it infuriates me because they speak with such authority.
Um, like they have all this data and that, that they're going off of that with, with these great success on something and they don't.
They're not even practicing 84.
It's just like some books that are written about cancer that, that aren't written by a person that treats cancer.
Where you coming up with the septal theoretical to sell a book.
Uh, that just bothers me. It's just like, where are the ethics and the morals of people?
Maybe you don't have a responsibility to your patient base because you don't have a patient base.
You don't have a responsibility to humanity.
When you're making claims that nobody can, nobody can justify those claims that you're making. It's just theoretical.
Um, you know, there's, I read a book on methylene blue.
A few years ago when methylene blue was this big thing and, and what's his name?
Polo was big and the methylene blue and it was taken methylene blue.
Of course he, that was one of his biggest sellers. He was selling methylene blue at the time.
And it's like, so I read a book on it and I read some looked up some data and the person that read a book.
All he does is write books on different natural things. He doesn't even do any of these things.
You're not a practitioner. You know, it's like, there's no, there's no, um, those people are immune to any, any, um, you know, um, backlash because, you know, they're just writing.
They're just writing to write a book that is, there's freedom of speech.
So we just, we just have to be careful in looking at the information that is out there is have a balance to view of it.
As all I'm saying, let's just look at it with a critic. I think we should look at everything with a critical eye.
Um, that's what I did when I got into all of this, you know, when I was first, you know, I got into the right machine when I was in school.
The lord didn't give me permission to buy my first rife when I was in school. That was in the early 1980s.
So the lord did give me permission to buy my first rife until 1998 was a long time.
Okay. So I had studied the rife and I picked out the right machine that I wanted and that changed over time when I was looking at different machines.
Of course, they so much approved since 1998 when I bought my first rife.
I decided this was going to be the right machine that I was going to buy when I was ready to buy it.
And I thought it was the best machine on the market at the time.
And I think it was, I think I was right.
And when that first patient came in in 1990 and finally I felt like the Holy Spirit gave me permission to buy a rife.
I took that lung for that door to be opened.
And then walk through that door and the rest is history.
But again, I would willing to make changes based upon what I think is the best and my knowledge and gaining knowledge over time what I think is the best.
And being very careful, you know, I take, you know, when I'm trying to figure out what's the best thing for you and people that God has given me
to watch over, I take that responsibility as a very grave responsibility.
So I'm not going to lead you down the road just because we can sell a product or something.
Or because there's a lot of hype behind it.
So I want to be that factor that maybe puts the brakes on sometimes.
This says let's think about this. Let's pray about this.
Let's be wise about this. Let's ask for wisdom about this.
And let's use discernment in our judgment before we jump on a pen bandwagon that will, you know, could possibly make us look like a fool afterwards.
So, or could hurt us. So let's just be careful with all of that.
All right. Any other questions?
All right. Thank you for everybody being on.
Remember to be praying for one another and praying for us in our protection.
We'll be praying for you each one of you.
I love you all. We all love you all.
And we'll see you next week.
All right. Bye-bye.